fueron siete entre ellos susan collins
del estado de maine vio casi y de
luisiana
pat toomey de pennsylvania richter pour
de carolina del norte mitt romney de
yuta que durante los cuatro años de
administración de donald trump se opuso
a las políticas del ex presidente lisa
murkowski de atlanta
pensás que curiosamente estaba el 6 de
enero en la casa blanca cuando los
simpatizantes violentos de donald trump
se tomaron el capitolio que están
diciendo varios analistas es que pues
esto representa más unión para el
partido republicano que en las últimas
semanas se había cuestionado lo dividido
que quedaba tras la administración de
donald trump es decir a pesar de que
algunos republicanos senadores
republicanos hayan dicho que
efectivamente había incitado a esta
violencia pues el voto confirmó el
respaldo de estos senadores republicanos
hacia donald trump y esto significa
entonces más unión y pues evitar así la
posibilidad de que donald trump como loa
en el pasado cree un nuevo político un
nuevo partido político de derecha y
entonces pues sigue haciendo los
republicanos lo que representen es el
lado conservador y de derecha que en
eeuu
cristóbal y rápidamente cuéntanos cómo
transcurrió esta quinta y última jornada
del impeachment y cuáles son las
principales reacciones en eeuu
pues justo después de que se conociera
el resultado nancy pelosi y los nueve
administradores fiscales demócratas
representantes a la cámara ofrecieron
una rueda de prensa nancy pelosi dijo
que los senadores republicanos fueron
cobardes a no poder tomar posición
frente al ex presidente de donald trump
a pesar de saber que los hechos lo
indicaban claramente donald trump hábil
incitado a la violencia el 6 de enero
james rating que estuvo liderando el fin
del lado que acusaba a donoso también
dijo que su caso fue claramente expuesto
y que lamenta que los senadores
republicanos no hayan tomado posición
también pues es de mencionar la reacción
obviamente de mitch mcconnell líder
republicano en el senado quien dijo que
donald trump claramente fue moralmente
prácticamente responsable de los hechos
de violencia